i like that uh
point about education i think the other
part would be which is one above that is
guys got to get involved in politics and
office they got to get involved there as
well i think some of the guys from the
crypto community you have to get
involved in political you know arenas
congress senate governor even some being
inspired to go into
presidency look at the president of el
salvador what kind of an edge he has i
think the strategy for a guy like you
going and talking maybe a part of it is
also inspiring some of these other guys
who want to pursue politics because you
know most of the world when we think
about oh my gosh warren buffett he
doesn't believe in bitcoin oh my gosh
bill gates is against bitcoin peter
schiff says bitcoin's going to zero
which i believe you said in 2013
bitcoins going to zero but you flipped
you started educating and getting a
little bit more clear and then you went
to a different direction even monger
recently said charlie munger said the
following he says i wish
it and this was last week i wish it had
been banned two weeks ago immediately
and i admired the chinese for banning it
can you imagine charlie munger a
capitalist agreeing with china monger
said wednesday a daily journal corp
annual meeting which was held virtually
i certainly didn't invest in crypto i'm
proud of the fact i've avoided it it's
like a venereal disease or something i
just regarded as beneath contempt
the 98 euro billionaire has been long
critic of bitcoin previously calling it
rat poison
and uh i mean he just
certainly the great short squeeze in
gamestop was wretched access certainly
the bitcoin thing is wretched access i
would argue that venture capital is
throwing too much money too fast and
they're considerable rich access and
venture capital and other forms of
private equity and he just doesn't stop
he keeps going and going and going so
the world looks at these guys the people
who have been influencers in the finance
world for a while
who are totally against it
and then
somebody sits there and says well
i i i trust buffett more than i do
michael
why should i believe these guys that are
talking about bitcoin what you're saying
is a shock wave moving through the
culture
you're seeing the most disruptive force
in the world right now and it's slamming
into people and institutions faster than
they can
then they can absorb it and and
appreciate it and understand it
and this is like shock waves in the real
world right if i move an airfoil through
the air faster than the speed of sound
the speed of sound is the rate at which
air communicates with itself the air
can't get out of the way i pound into it
i create massive turbulence and noise
the way to solve it is you go slower but
you know then you're not supersonic
you know charlie monger wasn't an
advocate of apple computer
right how about amazon right how about
how about microsoft right
warren buffett's a friend of bill gates
for how many years and he still hasn't
bought microsoft stock and microsoft is
an idea that was
you know
fairly well understood 40 years ago 30
years ago
so um
what you have is is uh something so
powerful that everyone's being asked to
have an opinion right
presidents
you know the president of russia the
president of most nation states they're
asked to have an opinion every
investor's asked to have an opinion
but what if i told you you couldn't
really understand it without a hundred
hours of time invested
how many people after the age of 40
spend 100 hours studying anything
you know
like once you get to how about age of 65
you don't think of monger buffett gates
these guys spent 100 hours studying
bitcoin aren't you sure they didn't
isn't it obvious
i i would say it's almost certain that
he hasn't spent 10 hours and so i like i
i would say the same with most macro
investors though right now you know what
i would say the same with a lot of
crypto investors the world is full
okay how many people
i mean i see it because i see in my feed
most people in the crypto space devin
spent a hundred hours studying this
how many people have spent a hundred
hours studying the stock that they hold
in their portfolio true how many people
spend a hundred hours studying facebook
yeah based on what you're saying you
don't need to study bitcoin just trust
you and buy bitcoin no no he's not
saying that he's not yeah but i'm not
saying that i'm saying that i spent a
thousand hours before
what i'm saying is you're basically
saying look i've done the research you
don't need to do it yourself just buy
bitcoin and hold it for 100 years have a
great day bye it's basically what you're
saying
i i'm actually saying that people should
do the research until they get the
conviction necessary to make their own
decision
okay
like in the day this is property i don't
run a i'm not promoting my own security
right promoting an exchange i'm
basically suggesting
go west young man get some land
right it's like go get go go to america
right get some property and make a life
for yourself but you decide whether
you're wanting to do that or not
here's the more important point though
it's
every single influential person in the
world is being asked to have an opinion
but they're not spending a hundred hours
on the opinion
if i rolled the clock back a hundred
years and i went to every politician and
every rich person in the world in the
year 1900 and i asked him what they
thought about electricity what do you
think they'd say right
how about how about airplanes in the
year 1904 what was the opinion then
so
it's not unreasonable
and i don't think we should be spending
a lot of time fixating upon the opinions
of
of
famous and powerful and rich people
about a technology that they have not
chosen to make a focal point of their
interest well especially when they're 98
years old like
i think it has to be a fact i think the
more important point is everybody thinks
for themselves
right so
you wouldn't go to charlie monger and
ask him to pick out stocks and your
stuff like name every winning stock in
the past decade
netflix google
apple
facebook amazon
how many of them were recommended to you
by
any of these people that you're getting
a penis on
none of none of the bitcoin antagonist
or critics would have recommended or did
recommend any of those
stocks right so it's it's kind of a
point it's really just marketing
or sparks that are being sent up because
what happens is these guys in the media
they interview them and they want to
like get a rise out of them so they
actually throw this out there nobody is
asking warren buffett's opinion of
silver or gold right now
because no one's interested in hearing
the answer so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you